This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's almost that time... ...for the Olympics. The pageantry, the dreams, breathtaking victories... ...for fans, it's an event of extraordinary drama. Athletes from across the globe competing at the very highest level at the limits of human endurance. Social scientists find the games equally compelling for what they reveal about human behavior.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。奥运会... ...快要开幕了。盛装的游行、梦想、令人惊叹的胜利... ...对粉丝来说，这是一场充满非凡戏剧性的活动。来自全球各地的运动员在人类耐力的极限水平上展开最高水平的竞技。社会科学家们发现，这些比赛同样引人入胜，因为它们揭示了人类的行为。
When a match ends, the winners and losers do something. That's immediate, automatic, it's unconscious, they have no control of it, it just happens. About a second later, then they come to their senses and they realize that they're on stage. And whatever rules they've learned to manage their expressions kick in then. Coming up, what the Olympics can teach us about human behavior from a professor who's also an Olympic judo coach. Stay with us. My guest today is David Matsumoto. He's a professor of psychology at San Francisco State University.
比赛结束时，胜者和败者会做出一些举动。那是即时的、自动的、无意识的，他们无法控制，事情就这样发生了。大约一秒钟后，他们回过神来，意识到自己正身处舞台之上。然后，他们为管理表情而学到的任何规则便开始发挥作用。接下来，一位同时也是奥运柔道教练的教授将通过奥运会教导我们有关人类行为的知识。请继续收听。我今天的嘉宾是戴维·马苏莫托。他是旧金山州立大学的心理学教授。
He's used the Olympics as a laboratory for psychological observations. But he's also been a part of the Olympics. David's coach the US Olympic judo team and his daughter has competed in the games. I'm going to talk to him today first about his research and then about what a sharp I'd psychologist might observe about human behavior at the games. David, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. You photographed 84 athletes from 34 countries who were competing in the 2004 Athens Olympics
他曾将奥运会用作心理学观察的实验室。但他也是奥运会的一部分。戴维曾执导过美国奥运柔道队，他的女儿也曾参加过比赛。今天我将首先与他谈谈他的研究，然后探讨一个敏锐的心理学家在奥运会上可能会观察到的人类行为。戴维，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。你拍摄了2004年雅典奥运会上
judo competitions, and you photographed them at the moments when they won or lost their matches. What did you find? Well, what you find is that people all around the world show exactly the same types of expressions depending upon whether they want to loss. So those who won a match, or won a medal, for example, invariably showed some kind of enjoyment smile. And those who lost the last match showed nothing sometimes, some of them showed sadness, some of them showed some kind of distress. But the interesting thing about these findings is that those patterns vary depending upon whether they won or lost, but they'd not vary across any of the countries or cultures that the athletes came from. Now most laypeople would not necessarily be surprised by this. They would sort of say, yeah, sure people win, they sort of look the same, but why is this interesting from a scientific
来自34个国家的84名参加柔道比赛的运动员，你在他们赢得或输掉比赛的瞬间为他们拍照。你发现了什么？嗯，你发现世界各地的人在赢或输比赛时，会表现出完全相同的表情。例如，那些赢得比赛或赢得奖牌的人，无一例外地都表现出某种享受的微笑。而那些输掉最后一场比赛的人则面无表情，其中一些人表现出悲伤，另一些人则表现出某种痛苦。但这些发现有趣的地方在于，这些模式会根据他们是赢是输而有所不同，但并不会因运动员来自的国家或文化而有所不同。现在，大多数普通人对此不一定感到惊讶。他们会觉得，哦，当然，人们赢了，看起来都差不多，但为什么这从科学的角度来看很有趣呢？
perspective? Well, it's interesting because actually before our study, there were many, many studies that have shown that similar types of patterns of findings, cross-cultural similarities in these expressions. But there was never a study that was done in what we call an ecologically valid environment out in the real world to show that people actually do this stuff in the real world outside of a psychology laboratory. And I was just very, very fortunate to be able to do this study at the Olympics, which is a perfect social psychological laboratory.
嗯，这很有趣，因为实际上在我们的研究之前，有很多很多的研充都显示过类似的研究模式，即这些表情具有跨文化的相似性。但从来没有人做过一项在我们所谓的生态有效环境（即现实世界）中进行的研究，以表明人们确实在心理学实验室之外的现实世界中做这些事情。而且我非常非常幸运能够在奥运会上开展这项研究，这是一个完美的社会心理学实验室。
In some ways, the study was basically making the argument, I suppose, that at least in the moment of triumph, people's reactions were shaped by what seemed like biologically innate imperatives. Yeah, that's exactly right. However, that study by itself fell a little short. So in actuality we had the second study which studied the Paralympic athletes and in every sport in the Paralympic has a different disability for judo. It's blindness. And so we compared the expressions of the blind athletes to those of the sighted athletes and we found exactly the same things. So these are athletes who've been blind. Some of them presumably blind from birth.
在某些方面，这项研究基本上是在论证，我想，至少在胜利的时刻，人们的反应是由看起来像是生物学上天生的必然性所塑造的。是的，完全正确。然而，这项研究本身有点不足。因此，实际上我们进行了第二项研究，研究了残奥会运动员，残奥会中的每个运动项目都有不同的柔道残疾类别。那就是失明。因此，我们将失明运动员的表情与视力正常的运动员进行了比较，我们发现了完全相同的结果。所以这些运动员一直是盲人。其中一些人大概是天生失明。
They presumably haven't really. Let's make it even clearer than that. We had athletes who are congenitally blind. So blind from birth, there's no presumption about what they've seen. They've been impossible to see those expressions. And the fact that they produce the same things on their faces for certain emotions
他们大概没有真正看过。让我们说得更清楚一点。我们有先天失明的运动员。也就是从出生起就是盲人，对于他们看过什么没有任何假设。他们不可能看到过这些表情。事实上，他们在某些情绪下会在脸上产生相同的反应，
and then their bodies for triumph, absolutely suggest that these things are biologically innate. What did the facial expression of triumph look like? Well triumph is actually a whole body response and involves the expansion of the chest, raising the hands, oftentimes with a fist, a little bit of fierce or aggressive look in the face and oftentimes a stern gaze at some kind of target. Now, one of the things you found, which I found really fascinating, was, yes, you do find evidence that some of these expressions are biologically innate,
而在身体上为胜利做出反应，绝对表明这些事情是生物学上天生的。胜利的面部表情是什么样的？嗯，胜利实际上是一个全身反应，涉及胸部的扩张、双手的抬起（通常握拳）、脸上带有一点凶猛或具侵略性的表情，并且通常对准某种目标有严厉的凝视。现在，你发现的事情之一，我发现真的很有趣，那就是，是的，你确实找到了证据表明其中一些表情是生物学上天生的，
but you also find that culture plays a huge role at the Olympics. Tell me about that part of the study. What we did was study the expressions across time. So, even though we were using a camera, we were using a camera that was shooting eight photographs a second. And so across a number of seconds, we can see how expressions transform across time. So immediately when a match ends,
但你也发现文化在奥运会上扮演着极其重要的角色。跟我讲讲研究的那一部分。我们做的是研究随时间推移的表情。所以，尽管我们使用的是相机，但我们使用的相机每秒拍摄八张照片。因此，在几秒钟内，我们可以看到表情是如何随时间转变的。所以比赛一结束，
the winners and losers do something. That's immediate, automatic, it's unconscious, they have no control of it, it just happens. About a second later, then they come to their senses It's not just immediate, automatic, it's unconscious, they have no control of it, it just happens. About a second later, then they come to their senses and they realize that they're on stage. And whatever rules they've learned to manage their expressions, kick in then.
胜者和败者就会做点什么。那是即时的、自动的、无意识的，他们无法控制，事情就这样发生了。大约一秒钟后，他们回过神来，它不仅仅是即时的、自动的、无意识的，他们无法控制，事情就这样发生了。大约一秒钟后，他们回过神来，意识到自己正身处舞台之上。然后，无论他们学过什么规则来管理自己的表情，都会在那时起作用。
And that's that second expression, or third expression sometimes, where you see these vast cultural differences. Some athletes are smiling, some athletes show nothing, some athletes start crying, some athletes do nothing, some athletes start crying, some athletes do something else. But it's very interesting how you see the change at that point, but cultural invariance at the beginning. You find that even though you have this range of emotions that kicks in after the first
这就是第二个表情，或者有时是第三个表情，在这里你可以看到这些巨大的文化差异。有些运动员在笑，有些运动员面无表情，有些运动员开始哭泣，有些运动员什么都不做，有些运动员开始哭泣，有些运动员做别的事情。但非常有趣的是，你如何看到那个时间点的变化，而开始时却是文化不变的。你发现，尽管在第一秒或最初几秒钟之后，你会经历这一系列的情绪，但这些并不是随机的，它们在某些方面实际上是由文化决定的，你确实会发现来自某些国家的运动员的表现与来自其他国家的运动员有可以预测的不同。是的，我们后来能够识别出这种文化变异的各种模式。所以有中和者，也就是那些几乎什么都不表现出来的人。作为刻板印象，你可以想到东方苏联集团
second or the first couple of seconds, these are not random, these actually are in some ways culturally determined that you actually find athletes from certain countries behave predictably differently than athletes from other countries. Yes, we were able to identify the various patterns of that cultural variation later on. So they're the neutralizers, those who kind of show nothing. As stereotypes, you can think of Eastern Soviet block
或者也可以想到集团国家、东欧，那些带有某种共产主义历史的国家，比如古巴，就是这样的。你可以想到减弱者，那些表现出某些东西但稍微有些柔和的人。有很多北美、西方的那种文化会这样做。还有那些在某些事情之后笑得很多的人，甚至那些没有发生消极事情的人，你可以想到东亚人就是那样的。所以是的，关于主要模式在文化调控中如何发展，存在着这些非常有趣的文化地理变异。换句话说，人们表达的可能是他们内心真正发生的事情，但随后
or also, the block countries, Eastern Europe, those who have some communist history in them, Cuba, for example, are like that. You can think of the de-amplifiers, those who show something but it's muted a little bit. There are a lot of North American, Western kind of cultures that do that. There's those that smile a lot after something, even those that are not have something negative, you can think of the East Asians as something like that. So yes, there's these very interesting cultural geographic variations on how the major patterns go in the cultural regulation. So in other words, people express what really maybe is happening inside them, but then the
文化开始发挥作用并说，这是你在这种情况下应该表现的方式。事实确实如此。我们大多数人之所以看不到那种即时的反应，是因为当事情发生时，我们往往在看着发生的事情。所以当我们看着那个事情发生的人时，他们已经处于文化调控的部分了。而像我们这样一直把镜头对准那个人的人，
culture kicks in and says, here's the way you ought to behave in the situation. That's exactly what it is in that. And the reason why most of us don't see that immediate reaction is because when something happens, we're often looking at the thing that happened. So by the time we look at the person who it happened to, they're already on the cultural regulation part. And it's people like us who have a camera on that person
一直在观察即时反应，我们就能捕捉到即时反应。关于奥运会最著名的研究之一，我们在《隐藏的大脑》的其他地方做过专题报道。这是康奈尔大学的托马斯·吉洛维奇与维多利亚·梅德维克和斯科特·梅迪共同进行的一项研究。他分析了巴塞罗那奥运会上奖牌得主面部的表情。他发现，总的来说，铜牌得主看起来比银牌得主更开心。
all the time, who are watching the immediate reactions, we can get the immediate reaction. One of the most celebrated studies looking at the Olympics, we featured it elsewhere in Hidden Brain. This is a study by Thomas Gillovich at Cornell, along with Victoria Medvek and Scott Medi. He analyzed the expressions on the faces of metal winners in the Barcelona Olympics. He found that in general bronze metal winners looked happier than silver medal winners.
我要让你告诉我这可能是为什么，以及你自己的研究是如何既丰富又对这一发现做出了细微的调整。嗯，我们发现了完全相同的事情。事实上，我们研究的伟大之处之一在于，我们不仅能够研究运动员在赢或输、就在垫子上时的表情。我们还可以在30分钟后的颁奖典礼中间追踪他们。所以我们看到，同一个结果的同一个人做了什么，但现在的社会背景不同了。你完全说得对。银牌得主，领奖台上的每个人都在笑。
I'm going to let you tell me why that might be the case but also how your own research both amplified and has a nuance to that finding. Well, we found exactly the same things. Actually, one of the great things about our study is that not only were we able to study the expressions of the athletes right when they want to lose, right when they're on the mat. We could follow them 30 minutes later in the middle of ceremony. So we saw what the same person did who had the same result, but it's now the social context is different. And you're exactly right. The silver medalist, everybody on the podium smiles.
所以这是毫无疑问的，因为这是一场非常公开的电视转播活动。但如果你测量微笑中移动的具体肌肉，你会发现，我们可以把银牌的微笑称为更多是痛苦的微笑，因为他们身上还有很多其他事情在发生。你可以看到，你不会看到眼角的皱纹。
So there's no question about it because this is a very public televised thing. But if you measure the exact muscles that are moving in the smiles, you find that, let's call the silver medal smiles more of the miserable smile, because they've got a lot of other things going on. You can see the, you won't see the crinkle in the eyes.
有时你会看到嘴角下垂，因为他们在微笑的同时真的很努力地去控制一些负面情绪。所以其中一些人在微笑时看起来很痛苦。吉洛维奇会认为，这是因为银牌得主在将自己与金牌得主进行比较，他们会说，如果我只快了半秒钟，如果我只跳得快一点点，我本可以成为，我本可以成为金牌得主。完全正确。所以当你看到铜牌得主时，
Sometimes you'll see the downturning of the lips, because they're really trying to control some negative feelings along with the smile. So some of them look miserable when they're smiling. And Gilevich would argue this is because a cell of metal winners are comparing themselves to the gold medal winners, saying if I only had gone half a second faster, if I'd only jumped a little bit faster, I could have been, I could be a gold medal winner. That's exactly right. And so when you get to the bronze medalist,
他们有更多理由感到高兴，因为另一种选择是一无所有。而银牌得主的另一种选择是金牌。因此，在我们的研究中，我们还发现铜牌得主比银牌得主表现出更多的享受微笑。我发现非常有趣的是，当我回顾我们的数据时，我们对这个铜牌得主现象发现的唯一例外是，有些铜牌得主看起来并不是很高兴。这些通常是前一年世界锦标赛的冠军，他们作为夺冠热门进入奥运会，但却不得不接受铜牌。因此，因为
they have more reason to be happier because the alternative is nothing. Whereas the silver medalist, the alternative was the gold. And so in our study, we also found that the bronze medalist had more of the enjoyment smiles than the silver medalist did. The only exceptions that we found to this bronze medalist thing that I thought was really interesting when I look back at our data, there are some bronze medalists who did not look very happy. And these were generally the winners of the world championships of the previous year who came into the Olympics as the favorite and they had to settle for bronze. So because
他们不得不接受铜牌，所以他们没有那些获得铜牌的人那么高兴，而且你知道，他们中的很多人根本没期望能获奖牌，或者他们只是很高兴能获奖牌。太迷人了。稍后回来，我将询问戴维关于他自己参加奥运会的经历，以及一位心理学家从担任教练和奥运选手父母的经历中可以学到什么。请继续收听。《隐藏的大脑》及以下内容的赞助支持来自第一共和银行。关于第一共和银行的一个有趣事实。第一共和银行是一家没有柜台窗口的银行，但他们并没有用计算机或机器人取代出纳员。
they had to settle for bronze, they were not as happy as those who are getting a bronze and they, you know, a lot of them didn't expect to get a medal or they were just happy to get a medal. Fascinating. When we come back, I'm going to ask David about his own experience of the Olympics and what a psychologist might learn from being a coach and being a parent of an Olympian. Stay with us. Support for Hidden Brain and the following message come from First Republic Bank. Interesting fact about First Republic. First Republic is a bank with no teller lines, but they didn't replace their tellers with computers or robots.
这怎么可能呢？私人银行家。每个客户都有自己的私人银行家，而银行家了解他们所有的客户。第一共和银行采用个性化的银行服务方法，致力于提供卓越的服务。请访问FirstRepublic.com听听他们客户的意见。第一共和银行，为您服务是我们的荣幸。赞助支持还来自LearnVest。LearnVest是一家在线财务咨询公司，致力于赋能全国各地的人们做出明智的理财决策。
How is that possible? Personal bankers. Every client has their own personal banker and bankers know all their clients. First Republic has a personal approach to banking, and they're dedicated to providing extraordinary service. Visit FirstRepublic.com to hear from their clients. First Republic, it's a privilege to serve you. Support also comes from LearnVest. LearnVest is an online financial advice company focused on empowering people nationwide to make good decisions
研究表明，写下你的目标会使你实现这些目标的可能性提高49%。这就是为什么当你与LearnVest合作时，你告诉他们你想实现什么，他们会为你制定定制的财务计划来帮助你实现目标。此外，他们还会为你配对一名财务规划师，帮助你保持正轨。要查看示例计划并获得50美元的额度，请访问LearnVest.com斜杠Brain。
with their money. Studies show that writing down your goals makes you 49% more likely to achieve them. That's why when you work with LearnVest, you tell them what you want to accomplish, and they create a customized financial plan to help you get there. Plus, they pair you with a financial planner to help keep you on track. To see a sample plan and get a $50 credit, go to LearnVest.com slash Brain.
嗨，我是克里斯·本德，《隐藏的大脑》的制作人之一。这里有一个收听我们节目的好方法。NPR1。这是一个手机应用，有点像潘多拉，但针对的是公共广播。里面充满了来自你喜爱的播客、NPR和你自己的当地电台的新闻和故事。无论你什么时候准备收听，NPR1都有适合你的精彩内容。请在你的应用商店中搜索NPR-O-N-E来找到它。
Hi, I'm Chris Bender of one of the producers of Hidden Brain. Here's a great way to listen to our show. NPR1. It's an app for your phone, kind of like Pandora, but for public radio. It's full of news and stories from your favorite podcasters, NPR, and the local station that you call your own. Whenever you're ready to listen, NPR1 has something great just for you. Find it on your app store, NPR-O-N-E.
好了，现在回到尚卡尔对心理学教授戴维·马松托关于奥运运动员背后科学的采访。[♪ 片尾曲播放 [♪ 请让我对奥运会柔道垫上运动员身上发生的事情的规模有一个概念。我的意思是，在生理上，他们身上发生了什么？我会告诉你规模的事情...在奥运会柔道垫上的运动员身上发生了什么。我的意思是，在生理上，那发生了什么？我会确切地告诉你发生了什么，因为我们实际上研究过这种事情。
All right, now back to Shankar's interview with Psychology Professor David Mutt Sumoto on the Science Behind Olympic Athletes. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Give me some sense of the scale of what's happening in an athlete on the judo mat in the Olympics. I mean, physiologically, what's happening to them? I'll the scale of what's happening in an athlete on the judo mad in the Olympics. I mean, physiologically, what's happening to that? I'll tell you exactly what's happening because we've actually studied this kind of thing.
如果你和我现在坐在这里进行这场对话，如果我们测一下心率，如果我们健康正常，我们大概是60、72左右。既然我们现在正在做一些非常令人兴奋的事情，也许我们的心率在80左右。如果你想象自己在慢跑，你可能会达到最大心率的70%，根据你的年龄，可能在1.3、1.4左右。在一场柔道比赛中，我们实际上测得运动员的心率达到了每分钟200次左右。哇。而且这些是高度调理的运动员。高度调理的，你必须高度调理才能达到每分钟200次的心率。而且这是在战斗条件下的每分钟200次。现在想想我在说什么。你将在战斗条件下以每分钟200次的心率进行清晰的思考，
If you and I are sitting down here right now having this conversation, if we clocked our heart rate, if we're healthy and normal, we probably about 60, 72, something like that. Since we're doing something that's really exciting right now, maybe we're at 80 or something. If you imagine yourself taking a jog, you might be at 70% of your max heart rate, which would maybe be at 1.3, 1.4 depending upon your age. In a judo match, we've actually clocked athletes heart rates around 200 beats a minute. Wow. And these are highly conditioned athletes. Highly, you've got to be highly conditioned to be at 200 beats a minute. And this is 200 beats a minute in combat conditions. Now think about what I'm saying. You're going to be at 200 beats a minute in combat conditions thinking clearly, being on
发挥出色的状态，在技术、战术和其他所有方面都确切地知道自己在做什么。要达到那个点，并不容易。这不是我们可以坐下来聊聊就能解决的。这不是我们可以坐下来聊聊就能解决的。这不是我真正能坐在这里像传统心理学家那样帮助你的事情。说实话，我必须让你进行大量的体力活动。我必须训练你的身体，以承受当你达到那种状态时身体产生的乳酸。
your game, knowing exactly what you're doing technically, strategically and everything else. To get to that point, it's not easy. It's nothing that we can sit around and talk about. It's nothing that we can sit around and talk about. It's nothing that I can really sit here and kind of help you like a traditional psychologist would. To tell you the truth, I've got to get you to be really physical. And I've got to train your body to tolerate the lactic acid that your body generates as I get you to that profile.
作为教练，你是如何让运动员在身体处于过度觉醒状态时继续思考的？嗯，首先，你必须让他们习惯处于那种过度觉醒的状态。所以有一个很长的时间段。我的意思是，我们说的是，这需要几年的时间，我们称之为周期化训练，才能让运动员达到身体的巅峰状态。一旦你到了那里，或者在通往那里的过程中，你可以做的是加入一些训练，
How do you get athletes as a coach to actually keep thinking when their bodies are in the state of hyperarousal? Well, first of all, you have to get them to be used to be that state of hyperarousal. So there's a long period of time. I mean, we're talking, it'll take several years of what we call periodized training to get an athlete to be at peak physical condition. Once you're there or condition. Once you're there or along the way you're there, what you can do is then add in some drills,
让运动员在达到那个水平后进行认知训练。例如，我可以创建一个场景，让运动员的心率上升到200。你知道，这不容易，这不好玩，你不会想成为那种人。但一旦你到了那里，我可以让你做一个填字游戏。对，我们过去常做的事情之一就是让人们绕着跑道跑，在跑道上冲刺800米，一旦他们离开跑道，
cognitive drills for athletes to do once they're at that level. So for example, I can create a situation where I'll get an athlete's hard rate up to 200. You know, it's not easy, it's not fun, you don't want to be that person. But once you're there, I can have you do a crossword puzzle. Right, one of the things that we used to do is we used to have people run around a track, sprinting the 800 meters around the track and once they come off the track,
解开这些打着结的巨大绳索，做这件事绝对让人沮丧。但你知道，当你的心率达到每分钟200次时，你必须应对这种挫败感，才能完成这个微小而复杂的认知任务。我发现最有趣的事情之一就是，奥运会的很大一部分其实是在电视摄像机的视线之外进行的。因此，运动员必须做好准备，他们必须热身。事实上，仅仅到达你的比赛场地本身就是一场斗争，特别是如果你在第一天就参赛的话。嗯，你说得完全对，因为观看这些运动的大多数公众，
untied these humongous ropes with knots in them, which is entirely frustrating to do. But you know, you got to deal with the frustration when your heart is going at 200 beats a minute to do this little complex cognition task. One of the things that I'm fine so fascinating is that so much of the Olympics actually happens out of sight of the TV cameras. So athletes have to get ready, they have to warm up. In fact, just getting to your competition itself can be a struggle, especially if you're competing on day one. Well, you're exactly right because most of the public who watch these sports,
顺便说一句，他们很棒，如果没有我们的粉丝，我们不会在这里，但大多数公众只是打开电视看到这种巅峰表现，而比赛对运动员来说可能排在第三位。也许这是主要事情，但它总是排在第三位，
who are great, by the way, we wouldn't be here without our fans, but most of the public just turns on the TV and can see this peak performance and competition really is maybe the third thing that the athletes are worrying about. Maybe it's the main thing, but it's always the third thing,
我们总是最关心的第一件事。第一件事是控制体重，因为在柔道中，你有一个体重级别。所以，每个人都有我们所说的日常体重。每个人的日常体重都比他们的体重级别要重。所以你必须制定一个计划，在称重前不久减掉一定的重量。然后你，每个人都有一套减重常规，减重可不好玩，跟20个正在挨饿的人在一起也不好玩，如果你不得不处于饥饿模式一个星期、10天，无论那是多久，这都是一段痛苦的经历，不，有些人比其他人更能应付，但这并不是你想用你的生命去做的事情，而且大部分时间都是这样，所以这是运动员考虑的第一件事。
the first thing that we're always worrying about. Number one is making weight, because in judo, you got a weight division. And so, and everyone is, we call it walking around weight. Everyone's walking around weight is heavier than what their weight division is. So you got to be on a program to cut down to a certain amount right before you're weighing in. Then you, everyone's got a routine to cut to weigh in and it's not fun cutting weight and it's not fun being with 20 people who are starving themselves and if you have to be in starvation mode for a week 10 days whatever that is it's a miserable experience no some people do that better than others but it's not the thing that you think
第二件事是什么？第二件事是时差。奥运会在里约举行。如果你来自我居住的地方，也就是旧金山，你距离那里有四个小时的时差。所以你必须考虑这四个小时的时差。如果奥运会是在雅典举行，就像2004年那样，现在我们说的是10个小时的时差。
that you want to be doing with your life and most of the time so that's the first thing that the athletes thinking about about. What's the second? The second thing is the jet lag. So the Olympics are in real. And if you're coming from where I live, which is San Francisco, you're four hours away. And so you have to think about the four-hour difference. If the Olympics were in Athens, like they were in 2004, now we're talking about a 10-hour difference.
2020年奥运会将在东京举行。现在我们说的是如果你在旧金山，反方向就是9个小时的时差，这些都是巨大的差异，因为如果你谈论的是巅峰表现，你希望人们得到充分休息、营养良好、处于精神巅峰状态，而如果你在第一天比赛，这就尤其困难，而且你想参加开幕式，人们对开幕式的了解是，无论在哪个国家，它通常在午夜左右结束，每个人都必须登上当地委员会安排的巴士，那简直是一片混乱。那简直就像动物园一样，很多运动员都会迷路。
Olympics are going to be in Tokyo in 2020. Now we're talking about nine-hour difference the other way if you're in San Francisco and these are big differences because if you're talking about peak performance you want people to be rested well, fed well, in peak mental condition and it's especially difficult if you're competing on day one and you want to be in the opening ceremonies and the thing that people don't know about the opening ceremonies is it usually ends around midnight wherever the whole country is and everyone's got to get on a bus that the local committee sets up and it's just chaos. It's just a zoo so many athletes get lost.
巴士不知道该去哪里，所以你可能在12点上车，而你可能在凌晨3点才能回到村里，而你可能在早上6点有称重时间。所以很明显，如果你那样做了，这会对你的比赛产生负面影响。事实证明，飞往东方和飞往西方去参加比赛并不是一回事。在某些方面，如果你碰巧朝某个方向飞行而不是另一个方向，这对人体更好。是的，事实上，朝一个方向走比朝另一个方向更容易，因为我们的身体天生更适合在25小时的周期内运作，而不是24小时的周期。这就是为什么我们保持清醒比早起更容易，这转化为旅行时就是，当我们向西旅行时，我们的时区变得
Buses don't know where to go and so you might get on your bus at 12 o'clock and you might be back in the village at 3 a.m. and you might have a 6 a.m. way in time. And so obviously if you did that, it kind of screws you up for that competition. It turns out that flying east and flying west to get to the games is not the same thing. That in some ways it's better for the human body if you happen to be flying in one direction rather than the other. Yes, in fact, it's easier to go in one direction rather than another because our bodies are built to function better on a 25 hour cycle than a 24 hour cycle. That's why it's easier for us to stay up longer than it is to get up earlier and how that translates to travel is when we travel west our time zones are getting
更晚了。所以我们只需要晚一点睡。对，晚一点睡，这更容易。当我们向东旅行时，就像我从旧金山来，现在我在华盛顿特区，这是一个三小时的时差。所以今天早上我必须在七点钟到达某个地方，那是我那里的四点钟，这意味着我必须在我那里的三点钟起床，这更困难。所以是的，我们把这些因素考虑在内。你知道，我想当没有去过奥运会的人想到奥运会时，它看起来非常迷人，非常有趣。你知道，你
later. So we just have to stay up a little later. Yeah, stay up a little later and that's easier. When we travel east like I came from San Francisco and here I am in DC now, that's a three hour time zone. So this morning I had to be at a certain place at seven o'clock which is four o'clock my time, which means I had to get up at three o'clock my time, which is more difficult. So yes, it's, it's, we take these kinds of factors into account. You know, I think when people think about the Olympics who haven't been there, it seems very glamorous, very fun. You know, you're on't been there, it seems very glamorous, very fun.
在这个世界舞台上，每个人都在看着你，每个人都在为你欢呼，每个人都希望你做得很好，当成功时为你鼓掌，你处于巅峰表现。这似乎是你生命中、教练组生命中等等的一段辉煌时光。当你身处其中时，感觉真的是这样吗？嗯，我不能代表其他人。我必须说，在我去过的四届奥运会和12次世界锦标赛中，我从未感到过那种辉煌的时刻，因为作为教练组成员，首先，在每个人都完成比赛之前，你的心情是不会结束的。
You're on this world stage, everyone's watching you, everyone's cheering for you, everyone's hoping that you do well and they clap for you when you succeed and you're at peak performance. And it seems like it's sort of a glorious time in your life, in the life of the coaching staff and so on. Is that how it actually feels when you're there? Well, I can't speak for everybody else. I got to say that I never felt that glorious times in the four Olympics and the 12 world championships that I've been to because as a coaching staff member, first of all, you're not done with your feelings until everyone's done competing.
而不幸的是，我从未遇到过团队中的每个人都获得金牌的情况。如果发生了那种情况，我想在比赛结束后一切都会是辉煌的。但无论我们的团队表现多好，无论是我的本地团队还是奥运团队，还是我们谈论的任何团队，只要有一个人没有成功，如果有一个人没有得到他们想要的，我都能感同身受。我可以有9名选手获得金牌，如果有一个人获得银牌，我当然很高兴，但这会留在我心中。
And unfortunately, I never had the situation where everyone on my team got a gold medal. If that happened, I think after the competition everything is glorious. But no matter how good our team did, whether it's my local team or the Olympic team or whatever teams we're talking about, if there's one person that didn't make it, if there's one person that didn't get what they wanted, I felt it. I could have nine players take a gold and if one person took a silver, I of course I'm happy, but it lingers for me.
我想这对很多人来说都是真的。我给你举个好例子，当我的女儿在2008年进入奥运代表队时。在奥运选拔赛中，她在决赛中的竞争对手是我道场的另一位女性。所以作为一名柔道教练，你的两名选手进入了奥运选拔赛的决赛，你知道你稳了
I think that's true for a lot of people. And I'll give you a good example of this when my daughter made the Olympic team in 2008. At the Olympic trials, her competitor in the finals was another woman from my dojo. And so as a judo instructor, you have two of your players in the finals was another woman from my dojo. And so as a judo instructor, you have two of your players in the finals of the Olympic trials, you know, you're golden
因为无论谁赢了，都会有人来自你的道场去加入奥运代表队。但其中一个竞争对手是你的女儿。其中一个是我的女儿，另一个是我视如己出的学生。最重要的是，当我们在比赛时，我没有女儿，我只有一个选手。
because no matter who wins, someone's from your dojo's gonna go and be on the Olympic team. But one of the competitors as your daughter. One of them is my daughter, and the other one is my student who I treat like a daughter. And on top of that, when we're in competition, I don't have a daughter, I have a player.
你知道，我女儿知道这一点，我们都知道这一点，我在比赛中对待我女儿就像对待其他人一样。现在，比赛结束后，她是我的女儿。但当我们在比赛时，她是另一个选手，我必须像对待其他人一样对待她。所以无论如何，我们有这两位选手要对决。对此我百感交集。
You know, and my daughter knew that, and we all knew that, and I treated my daughter like anybody else in competition. Now, after competition, she's my daughter. But when we're in competition, she's another player, and I got to treat her like I treat everybody else. And so anyway, we have these two players coming up. And I have mixed feelings about that.
你知道，当我的女儿赢了，我为她感到高兴，但我为输掉比赛的另一个选手感到非常难过。所以在那之后，这种经历可以说是苦乐参半。而且，是的，我的意思是我不想剥夺我女儿作为父母的身份。如果我能把我的感受纯粹作为父母来隔离的话，是的，很好，我很高兴。
You know, when my daughter won, I was happy for her, but I was very sad for my other player who lost. So after that, it was a very bitter sweet thing to have. I have occurred. And yeah, I mean, I don't want to take anything from my daughter as a parent. If I could compartmentalize my feeling solely as a parent, yeah, great, I'm happy.
但没有人能做到100%隔离，我也做不到。所以作为一个父母，我觉得很好，作为一个教练，我觉得又好又不好，这是一种复杂的感情，我至今仍然有这种感觉。我现在依然能非常清晰地记得。当你现在观看奥运会时，假设你不在奥运会现场，假设你不去，你要去里约吗？不。好吧，所以当你现在在电视上观看奥运会时，你在看什么？你注意什么？结合你作为一个研究过奥运会的心理学家、作为去过奥运会的教练、作为奥运选手的父母所知道的一切？
But no one can compartmentalize 100% where I couldn't. And so as a parent, you are great, I'm happy. But no one can compartmentalize 100% where I couldn't. And so as a parent, I feel good, as an instructor, I feel good and bad, and it's mixed up feelings that one had, and I still have it to this day. I remember it very clearly right now. When you watch the Olympics now, and let's say you're not at the Olympics, let's say you're not going to, are you going to Rio? No. Okay, so when you watch the Olympics on television now, what is it that you're watching? What is it that you pay attention to knowing all that you know as a psychologist who studied the Olympics as a coach, who's coached to the Olympics as a parent at the Olympics?
你现在寻找什么？我今天看很多东西，当我看到任何类型的巅峰表现时，不一定非得是体育。甚至当我看到任何类型的巅峰表现时，不一定非得是体育。甚至当我看着舞者或某个擅长做某件难以做到事情的人时，他们让它看起来那么容易。我自然而然地会想到那个人为了能够做到我们看到的毫不费力的动作而付出的汗水、泪水、鲜血和多年的努力。当你身处比赛时，你谈论的是几年准备中的几分钟、一小时。
What do you look for now? I look at a lot of things today, and when I see peak performance of any type, doesn't have to be sports. Even when I see peak performance of any type doesn't have to be sports. Even when I look at dancers or somebody who's really good at doing something that's difficult to do, they make it look so easy. And I automatically think about the sweat and the tears and the blood and the effort for years that that person put in to be able to do that that we saw that was just effortless. When you're at competition, you're talking about, you know, a few minutes, an hour of years of preparation.
你无法将你的记忆与那些年的准备工作割裂开来。这些事情实际上压倒了我。所以当你在想运动员时，你实际上是在想所有那些我们在电视上看不到的时光，所有那些早上四点起床、周末练习、放弃生活其他方面的时光，不仅是为了那些获胜的人，也是为了所有其他在那里的人。绝对的。我的意思是，每个人都做出了巨大的牺牲。当然，选手或运动员永远是付出第一牺牲的人，但想想他们所有的支持团队。对我们来说，我们在垫子上的每一个选手背后，都有一个10人或20人的支持团队，只是为了把那个人送上垫子。
And you can't divorce your memories from those years of preparation. Those things overwhelm me actually. And so when you're thinking about the athletes, you're actually thinking about all of those the times that we're not seeing on television, all of the waking up at four o'clock in the morning and practicing on the weekends and giving up other aspects of your life, and not just for the people who win, but also for everybody else who's there. Absolutely. I mean, everyone's made a huge sacrifice. And of course, the player or the athlete is always the number one sacrificeer, but think about all their support staff. For us, for every player that we had on the mat, we had a support team of 10 or 20 just to get that person on the mat.
所以，一个人身后，是一支军队。每个人都在同一个团队中，他们从未分享过风头。他们从未成为聚光灯的焦点。他们只是分享着他们帮助这个人实现了巅峰表现的知情权。当那个人赢了，每个人都感觉很好，而当那个人输了，每个人都感觉糟透了。当我看到这些事情时，我的心不仅向运动员倾注，也向所有这些人倾注。
And so, behind one person, there's an army. And everyone's on the same team, and they never share the limelight. They never get the spotlight. They just share in the knowledge that they help this person have a peak performance. And when that person wins, everyone feels good and when that person loses, everyone feels awful. And it's all those people, as well as the athletes, that my heart actually reaches out to when I see these things.
戴维·蒙特莫特拉，我想感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。我的荣幸，谢谢你。本期《隐藏的大脑》由克里斯·班德拉耶夫制作，珍妮·施密特剪辑。我们的团队还包括卡拉姆·奥卡卡利森、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克。你可以在推特、脸书和Instagram上关注我们，并在你的当地公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这很有帮助。我是尚卡尔·韦达安瑟姆，这里是NPR。你本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
David Montemortra, I want to thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure, Thank you. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Chris Banderayev and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our staff also includes Karam Okarkallisson, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. You can follow us on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram and listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, give us a review. It helps. I'm Shankar Veda Antham, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
大卫·蒙特莫特拉，感谢您今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。不用谢，谢谢你。本期《隐藏的大脑》由克里斯·班德拉耶夫制作，珍妮·施密特剪辑。我们的员工还包括卡拉姆·奥卡尔卡利森、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克。您可以在推特、脸书和Instagram上关注我们，并在您当地的公共广播电台上收听我的节目。如果您喜欢这一集，请给我们好评。这很有帮助。我是尚卡尔·韦达·安瑟姆，这是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。